Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
Here is a sad voicemail from a guy
whose sister appears to have lost it.
Speaker 4: Hey, David. Somehow, me and my sister
diverged on beliefs a couple of years back,
and now she is a hardcore anti-vaxxer. And she's
got a habit of seeing things so stupid that they
baffle me and I don't know how to respond. And
she says these things with such conviction and
authority that I don't have an immediate comeback.
Yeah. And in her head, that makes her right. She
thinks I can't say anything back because I'm wrong
and she's right when in reality, I don't even know
where to begin explaining how dumb she sounds.
Speaker 1: This is. This is the Sam Harris thing
from his podcast a couple of months ago about why
he hasn't done a debate with Bret Weinstein or
whoever else. And Sam Harris has explained it is
really easy to start a series of small fires that
are very difficult for even someone who's prepared
to put out. And that as soon as someone goes,
well, whoever you think vaccines work. What about
the Zimbabwean study that showed everybody got
worms from the vaccine and then died of COVID
anyway? And then you go, Well, I don't know.
I didn't see that study legit. I'm not sure
I'm not exactly prepared. And then the person
bringing it up feels emboldened as if they are
right. That's exactly what Sam Harris described,
which is what the caller is talking about here.
Speaker 4: The latest example? The reason I'm
calling you. He sent me a meme with a child in
the father that says, Dad is Santa Claus fake.
And the dad says, Of course not, son. Think
of how many people would have to be in on it.
And comparing Santa Claus to COVID 19, yeah.
Anyone with half a brain can see how
stupid that is. I don't even know
where to start trying to explain that. You know
Speaker 1: it. I hate to say this to the caller,
but it may not be worth trying to explain it.
I mean, the the question is, what would be
your goal? Is it just to change her mind? Or is it
because you believe she's a node of disinformation
if it's the former? I may not even bother
because that that that is extremely weaponized
disinformation. We've got a great bonus show
for you today. We will talk about the passing of
former Senate leader Harry Reid at age 82,
a very important historic political figure
of the late 20th century in the Senate. I would
say Oklahoma Republicans are introducing a bill
to limit how slavery is taught in schools,
of course. And we will talk about Dr. Oz's
campaign already off to a bad start. All
of those stories and more on today's bonus
show. Sign up at Join Pacman dot com! Don't
miss the second to last bonus show of 2021.